the earth circles the Sun but this orbit
is unstable over hundreds of thousands
of years it changes swinging the planet
further out into space and pivoting on
its axis at the furthest point and its
orbit and with the northern hemisphere
tilted away from the Sun the earth cools
2.4 billion years ago something turns
this natural cooling into a global
catastrophe it is one of the most
dangerous things in all the universe
life tiny organisms populate the oceans
there's no oxygen around and that's the
way most of them like it but then a new
kind of bacteria evolves cyanobacteria
and these guys create a serious gas
problem imagine earth billions of years
ago there's no oxygen everybody's happy
then so I know bacteria start making
oxygen it's a toxic pollutant if there
was a regulatory agency at the time they
would have been outlawed eventually
they'd polluted the whole world they had
really precipitated an ecological crisis
of global proportions the great oxygen
crisis upsets the greenhouse effect that
keeps the planet warm and with the earth
at its furthest point from the Sun
global temperatures plummet the ultimate
culprit is biology biology makes a mess
of the planet produces oxygen the oxygen
destroys the greenhouse effect of
methane and that freezes up the earth
2.4 billion years ago ice creeps out
from the poles
instead of warming the planet sunlight
bounces off the ice temperatures fall
creating more ice which bounces more
sunlight back into space and so on and
so on until the cooling becomes
unstoppable the ice marches on
temperatures plunge to an average of
minus 74 degrees
the blue planet turns white it's a
snowball earth and incredibly this may
have happened not once but at least
three times over the following billion
years as the planet lurched around the
Sun but throughout all of this and
against all the odds a handful of
species clung to life thanks to
volcanoes
even in an earth that was that was
covered almost entirely by ice volcanoes
would have been punching through that so
you'd certainly have pockets of water
lying about then life was able to carry
on and get through these cold periods
and the whole time the volcanoes that
help sustain life have been pumping out
carbon dioxide as this greenhouse gas
increases the atmosphere warms until 640
million years ago the last great
snowball earth ends and the survivors
emerge into a new world